now my friends across the political
aisle are cheering the Supreme Court's
5-4 decision today that struck down on
vagueness grounds a federal immigration
statute that triggered deportation for
individuals convicted of violent crimes
the illegal alien in the case had been
arrested for burglary which both the
Obama and Trump DOJ argued should
trigger deportation why
since the defendants conduct posed a
significant risk of violence well Neil
Gorsuch of course the newest justice of
the court applied a textualist approach
in deciding to join the liberal justices
in the majority justices Roberts Thomas
Aledo and Kennedy dissented on grounds
that the statutes language was plenty
clear but look setting aside which
theory of statutory interpretation is
most faithful to the Constitution do any
of you wonder why this is an issue at
all
I mean look anyone here illegally except
the daca people is potentially a
deportable alien under current law in
other words if you don't have permission
to be here go home well maybe the
government can't deport 12 million
people we hear that all the time but
certainly they could deport a lot if
they wanted to but Democrats however are
not interested in enforcing the law
instead they're interested in growing
their voter rolls and the Democrats they
don't even recognize victims of illegal
alien crime now remember according to
reports Jamil Shaw's father said he
never received a call from President
Obama after he lost his son but remember
he found time President Obama to call
that other victim Sandra Fluke but I
digress Governor Jerry mr. sanctuary
Brown was in Washington today and he was
asked about the cities in California
rejecting his sanctuary policies well
remember the sanctuary laws forbid state
and local police agencies from even
notifying the federal government when
incarcerated
illegals are about to be released onto
the streets leaders of these local
community ons from mayor's to sheriffs
are saying that your law favors the
rights of criminal illegal aliens over
the rights and the safety of those
communities your response absolutely
false and I'd like to see a scintilla of
evidence that would support such an
unlined landish Foxx proposition it's
not a fox proposition I think Fox News
exploits this year we have criminals
that do horrible things all the time
which ones may be documented which ones
are obligated to look at that but we
have a very strong law enforcement
community in the state and I think the
scapegoat the immigrants by these very
biased stories I want to protect people
and for you to say that we don't care
about victims he's really a coma well
with all due respect to use his language
some of your own county officials are
saying your policies don't seem to care
about victims past or future and just
yesterday Los Alamitos voted 4 to 1 to
align themselves with the Trump
administration in opposing brown
sanctuary state policies and today San
Diego County voted to do the same Wow so
how long can Jerry Brown allow this to
go on he's tearing his state apart and
he's endangering its citizens and now
Brown is even waffling on his response
to the president's call to send National
Guard troops to protect the border well
governor Moonbeam says he's willing to
send 400 troops so long as they have
nothing to do with immigration
enforcement what are they gonna do build
schools build wall what is it what the
heck they're supposed to do well
regardless of the threat they might
present to the citizens of California
illegals they're always welcome so long
as liberals are in charge there now this
is California Democratic congressman
brad Sherman who was with me on the
angle a few weeks ago
look you have more crime in California
than Wyoming because you have more
people in California we tell the
American people tonight that if you
because the California wants to be
sanctuary fugitive state whatever you
want to call it we have to sacrifice a
certain number of Americans for this
utopian idea that borders are pointless
the fact is if you want less crime move
to the Cayman Islands they got so few
people here they're there you can go a
whole week without a without a violent
crime that so that's their argument if
you want to be safe from illegals move
to the Cayman Islands my friends this is
madness as I often say if enforcing our
immigration laws spares one American
from death or rape or theft or abuse
it's worth it even in California and
that's the angle